this is a production of Cornell
University
so in 2003 I was invited the chelating
to participate in to us symposium they
were having at the Catholic University
Valparaiso on sustainable AG and while
we were there they took us on a few side
trips and they showed us these hillsides
avocado plans that are kind of unique to
Sheila and I was pretty treat by the way
they're structured and the steepness of
the slopes and really interested as a
sort of soul management groundcover
management issue and I asked Eduardo I
Adele who's totally remember regarded
got a speech to hear about 10 years ago
is now professor there I said you know I
really like to have a student come to
Cornell and do a PhD on related to this
hillside avocado production system and a
couple of years went by and I kind of
[ __ ] Eduardo had forgotten about this
and then one day I got an email he said
I think he got just the right student
work on this project and she'll be
flying so Amaya chucho applied himayat
is from that Burchill a central chill a
little inland
rise up and she got her undergraduate
degree at the Catholic University
Valparaiso and that she worked for a
year under to get your degree 2004-2005
worked for a year with a guy named
francisco Gotti as a model who is one of
the kind of the Guru of avocado growers
he's a consultant history professor at
University and we put together a team
was kind of amazing to be able to do a
PhD project from seven or eight thousand
miles however far is the chi layaway but
it Amaya was able to do that with a
really good support team there and she
also came into an apple ground cover
management project that I had started in
1991 and it sort of scared away to
previous grad students who looked at the
amount of data and the number of years
are looking at 16 17 years worth of
cumulative data this experiment and Maya
basically just jump right in on that and
did a superb job of summarizing it she's
going to talk a little bit about both
the apple sold management project which
is up
lazy farm and the avocado research and
so I guess but never ever do my well
thank you for being here yes me instead
I'm going to talk about two projects
we'll start with a project that we did
here in apples that Ian started in 1991
and then I'm going to talk a little bit
about the project that we did they enjoy
first of all so I start thanking
everybody that has helped with this
project in a lot of help from people in
chilean here without them none of them
this would have ever ever been possible
and also out the funding sources sorry i
seed geneva people talking maybe I us
unmute we'll try that so the first
project that we presenting is that the
long-term effect of brand management
systems in a New York apple orchard the
objectives of this study was to
determine the impacts of ground cover
management system in tree growth the
nutrition production and also in the
sole physical and adequate condition for
several years as he has said it was it
starting 1991 and we follow it until
nineteen ninety-eight there were four
treatments a pre-emergent herbicide that
wasn't life aside applies twice during
the growing season sorry a pre-emergence
that was a residual herbicide that was
applied one one time during the growing
season and the four treatments were only
apply on the tree row all of the drive
lanes were kept with grass I
post-emergence that was glyphosate that
was applied twice a year a sought
treatment on a bark mulch treatment so
some of the results after the 16 years
we saw that at the beginning the
treatments with the herbicide were
bigger in terms of tree growth on us the
year one by this
and that we saw the beginning was what
everybody expected that the trees with
herbicide were going to have we're going
to be bigger than the trees with salt
because of the competition I always saw
that this trend kind of dissipated a
little bit and we saw huge increase on
three sides on the mulch treatment which
I was kept during all the following
years and in terms of the trees that
were kept bare soil that had no
competition with weeds or the ground
cover actually we saw that there were
much smaller and they grew less than the
trees that were we thought
in 1991 they excavated one tree per plot
and they divided in sections and they
dry it and measure the dry weight of the
trees so what we saw with that data it's
here you can see the below ground parts
of the tree and here's their pre herb
the poster the thought under mulch this
is this sequence is always the same is
oh it's always going to be the pre first
that posted were to see the Sun and the
multi for all the graph so we didn't see
any big difference in below ground there
were no a statistical difference but
sorry we saw only on the secondary roots
which were the routes between one
millimeter 21 centimeters and we didn't
see any difference above brown so that
was in 1991 that was a nine to ten years
after the trees were planted in terms of
fruit yield the first years we saw that
the trees on the herbicide tended to
have a little bit more fruit that the
trees are mulch and sought but the same
as what happened with a tree growth that
trend was not sustained over time and on
the last year's we didn't see any
significant difference
what happened with the soil I'm just
going to highlight a noise a lot of data
but one of the most important things in
terms of phosphorus calcium we saw that
the trees on mulch had much more
available nutrients than the trees on
the other treatments and there was not a
big difference in 2007 that was from 19
I was fifteen years after there was not
a big difference between the other three
treatments and we also saw some
significant difference in manganese and
the pH but one of the most striking
difference was in terms of total
nitrogen carbon and carbon to nitrogen
ratio in 2007 well in all of the years
actually that we measure it from 1999
2007 mulch treatment had the highest
percentage of nitrogen carbon and had
the highest ratio of carbon to nitrogen
it was significant different in all the
years so some of the big conclusions out
of this study well that as I just showed
the difference in soil nitrogen carbon
and oratius was much more higher in the
mulch treatment that in the ER besides
and the thought another very important
conclusion was that everybody expected
and I think that that's most of what you
can breathe in the literature and that's
what it makes this study so interesting
is that in the first year if you have a
short-term study on management system
you usually
that the trees that are with herbicide
and they have no competition tend to do
better than the trees that have a
granddaughter but this study shows that
that actually is not a trend that
sustains over time and that somehow the
trees not somehow differently the trees
on this sought treatment are able to
compensate for this competition but the
trees that are on bare soil the duration
of the soil the input that that has over
the performance of the trees much bigger
than the competition of the ground cover
and that treats and are able to get over
that deterioration of the soul but they
are able to compensate for the
competition and we saw that the post
emerging herbicide that is sick wife is
a treatment that we replaced twice
during the growing season was a really
good combination of with separation and
solvent servation so on the same
experiment we decided to come up with a
nutrient budget for this different brand
management systems there's a lot of
input in terms of herbicides and
fertilizers on these fortunes to have
really good productions so this
definitely has an impact on the
environment and we decide and so we
thought it was a good idea to do this
nutrient budget and figure out where all
these
fertilizer is going and also it's a way
to optimize our fertilization program
just to know which are the main posts on
what is going to what's happening with
with different neutral pools in the soil
and in the trees so the objectives I say
was to uh to measure and to budget the
major inputs and outputs of nitrogen and
we did in two years one year in 2005
with virtualization we applied 60
kilograms of nitrogen per hectare to the
to the orchard and we also apply some
phosphorus 25 kilograms per hectare and
then in 2007 it was a year was no
fertilizer at all so we could compare
what happens when we fertilize and we
don't fertilize the orchard so how did
we constructed the budget we measure the
inputs asked the fertilization in the
case of mulch we also measure how much
was being mineralized from the mulch
itself we measure what was only in the
amounts of nitrogen in other gregation
and the precipitation water and well as
i said the bark mulch in terms of
internal flexes we measure the amount of
nitrogen that was being recycled from
the surface vegetation and for that we
had a study on mineral bags there the
composition study we sample from
underneath the trees everything that was
measure a week sample a police i'm
falling immature fruits and the surface
vegetation we had a number of bags with
this combination of leader that we
previously measure the amount of
nitrogen had and we took it out in
different times i'm going to show how
much of it was being mineralized and how
much was left and that's how we
calculated the amount of nitrogen that's
been recycling from the surface
vegetation then we measure the amount of
nitrogen recycling from leaves and for
that we wrap one entire tree per plot we
collected all the leaves we took a
sample would dry them and we analyze it
for the content of nitrogen
and we did the same we took a sample of
phone booth and we also tried and
analyze it for the total nitrogen and
for the soul memorization we calculated
the soul Maron station based on the
potential mirror of mineral nitrogen for
that we had a soil incubation study and
then we corrected for the temperature on
the soil moisture that we were
continuously measuring this experiment
for the outputs we measure how much
nitrogen was made extracted from the
fruit so we harvest everything we took a
couple of samples of the food and we
analyze it for total nitrogen and we
back away the amount of nitrogen and we
also measure the amount of nitrogen
exiting the orchards through the surface
teaching for that each plot was
ideologically isolated and we had a
system in which there were during pipes
installed underneath this happened when
the experiment was established in 1995
now you want 1881 so all these pipes
would collect water and go to
underground extension and there we had
some tipping buckets that would measure
the flow and we would extract a sample
of water every time we had an event of
rainfall event or irrigation and we
would analyze that for nitrogen so we
had the volume and the consideration of
nitrogen so wicked back calculate how
much nitrogen was exiting through
diction and a very similar way to
calculate runoff here we have this
underground catchment
she where we would had the tipping
buckets with a data logger to measure
the flow and then the water would drain
into these pipes and go into that
tipping bucket so what are some of the
results in terms of the meter bag I'd
accomplishes the composition study we
saw in 2005 that the amount of nitrogen
being mineralized from the surface
vegetation in the mulch treatment which
was much higher than on the other three
treatments and also if you conferred
2205 to 2007 this is the year with
fertilizer and this is the year without
fertilizer we saw that the amount of
nitrogen that was me realized out of the
surface biomass with much higher
probably due to a higher level of
nitrogen and a lower carbon to nitrogen
integration and in 2001 seven we didn't
see much difference between the tremendo
much was also higher than the other
three treatments in terms of nitrogen
concentration in the runoff and
religious samples collected in 2005 and
77 in the run of the nitrogen
concentration was higher for the pre
herb treatment in 2005 and we didn't see
any difference in 2007 on in terms of
Nietzsche we saw that that actually the
mulch treatment tended to have higher
nature concentration of nitrogen and
lower run of concentration of nitrogen
and we saw that in 275 that the start
treatment also had a higher
nitrogen concentration in terms of water
flow the volume of water does are
exiting the orchard one of the
surprising observation is that much as I
said tended to hire a lower volumes of
runoff by higher volumes of leachate and
that's prolly due to all the effect that
the mouth has on the cell physical
property they prevent of the vault
density and the macro ferocity which
encouraged the infiltration of the water
and that's why we had more leachate than
run up so the final nitric the final
budget here are the four treatments the
first column for the Trinity is 2005 a
year with fertilizer and the second one
is 77 year without fertilizer so the
external inputs the most significant
number is in terms of the amount of
nitrogen that's being input through the
mulch minimization was pretty high for
2005 there was a year with fertilizer a
little bit lower in 2007 in terms of
internal fluxes the salt and the mulch
treatment had higher values for both
ears than the herbicide treatments on
overall you can see that the thought and
the mulch treatment had positive balance
for both ears not for the two herbicide
treatment they were only positive for
2004 the southern of five the year
Woodford
and they were deficient in nitrogen for
the year without fertilizer I probably
that is due to the it is due to the very
low internal fluxes because there's less
nitrogen that is being recycled compared
with the sought under much treatment so
some of the highlights the soil nitrogen
realization and recycle of the ground
cover minus accounted for over sixty
percent of internal flexes for both
years so that is it's pretty high sixty
percent of the nitrogen is being
recycled the fruit accounted for over
seventy percent of the nitrogen that's
being exported most of the nitrogen
losses are worth through religion rather
than run off regardless of the brand
management system and as I said there
were a positive balance for nitrogen
supply in just thought and in the mulch
treatment for four years and as I
explained the mulch treatment had a
highly filtration so there was a higher
volume of war Alicia water and also it
had high concentration of nitrogen
because of the new
the big input of nitrogen coming from
the immunization of all the mulch so
that could eventually you keep on an eye
much that could have a potential problem
with contamination and due to that we
decided to at the beginning the much was
ringing you every two years but after we
saw this really high increase in organic
matter and Tolan actually the soil we
started renewing the mulch every four to
five years so that was uh that's
interesting especially for organic
orchards that have all their nitrogen
input through composto biomass much and
as I said well the two herbicide
treatments had worked if were deficient
in nitrogen for the year without
fertilizer because of the very low
internal events beginning if the most
treatment was applied every year
periodically was applied from 1992 until
2002 it was a five every two years okay
I'm then we change it to two to four on
even five years yeah because of their
really high he put of my
that traumatic enough that even before
yes because the amount the regarding
maryland and the nitrogenous already
accumulated and linked to the organic
the high organic matter in the soil it
just stays there and also a big
difference with the next study that will
be shown is that this soil in general
have higher against matter naturally so
you put more and you're going to be
allowed to really fast so then I'm 2008
we started this study down in chile on
the impact of ground cover management
system on erosion and runoff an avocado
field site orchards a little bit of
background i know that most of you are
not familiar with avocados but chu is a
talk sport of avocado in the world and
as it happens almost in every place
where it's nice weather and this is a
beautiful area everybody wants to leave
in that area so what happens we have
this valley which really really nice and
rich soils where you want to grow fruit
but the city side starts expanding and
people want to have their second house
there to go to the weekend so the
growers decided to sell this it's a good
business and they said well what do we
do up let's go to the heel size it's a
cheaper
they have a technology to do it and in
the case of avocado to set up this
hillside it has a number of advantages
in terms of the production avocado is a
very clean crop in Chile because of the
weather conditions we only have rain
during the winter we have four to five
months of rain and the rest of the year
is dry so there's a lot of many
applications the refund your size or any
herbal sites that you had to do void
there avocados so if you set them up in
the in the hillsides you can have a
really good crop and really fast because
also the temperatures on the hillside
seem to be a little bit higher maybe one
or two degrees compared with the valley
and the biggest problem in this area
where they grow up because India is that
it gets a little bit cold during winter
so by just going to the hillside you can
escape this cold damage and that is uh I
mean it's very important for growers
because that differently it's a give
their play with having or not having any
any any production any crop so what they
do is they clean this hillside they take
away all the native vegetation I they
gather all the soils with an excavator
and they feel this sort of like racing
beds that we call berms and then they
said they plant the trees on top of the
berms here and they do this because they
think that they need at least a meter of
free soil for the avocado root system to
developed properly and if they would not
have this amount of soil I mean the
avocados would not would not do as well
so that's what they do with the first
year they clean everything they build
these berms and then the next year they
set up the trees so we decided to go
down there and to try to compare
difference of management system to see
what's happening with over the erosion
on the run off and we also wanted to see
what was going on with nutrient losses
with the herbicide residues are going
through this run of water and what is
the effect of the run cover management
on the tree growth the production we
also observe root growth on the sole
physical conditions so we had three
treatments are very sought treatment
that was the combination of terbutaline
and glyphosate that will apply it once a
year we had a ground cover treatment
there was a mixture of rye grass and
non-native legume and some native annual
grasses that was established in the
entire area when I mean entire area I
mean they were the trees are planted the
tree rose and these these are to raise
the bed it's the area between the
ditches that in the ditch error between
the two berms on top so it's everything
has ground cover and then a vegetation
script which is only the area in between
the two firms so in 2008 as I say we
went down there and we set up 15 of this
water catchment stations that consisted
of whole year we would catch all the run
of water coming from this section and it
would drain it into this barrel and once
the variables full of water and sediment
it would drain to this little tipping
back
that was attached to a logger and that
lager would record all the water flow
and we can back calculate and this is
how they looked after we left in 2008 we
had the brung over was just starting to
grow unfortunately this is a lot of work
as you can imagine we built 15 of these
and it's very steep it's fifty percent
slope so we could not we were not able
to have all the treatments established
before the end of the rain season so
some of the data that we collected for
2008 is a baseline because the treatment
were not established but if still we
were able to gather data and to see what
happens what would the growers would
normally do because they would keep it
completely free and even sometimes they
wait one or two years before they
prepare the site for planting the trees
so that was interesting data just to see
what happens when you just prepare the
soil and you leave those burns just
they're exposed to all the different
erosion agents so in 2010 this is how
the treatment fluke on the top left you
see the ground cover treatment and you
see that the trees in the ground cover
you see this more trees here well those
are replants because we didn't foresee
that we're going to have problems with
rabbits and hares and they decided that
the ground covers were excellent area to
have their little nest and eat our
tender and nice avocado trees so we had
some refunds and then on your right side
and top right you see the vegetative
strip it's clean on top and then you see
the
ground cover and the ditch area and on
the bottom is the bare soil treatment
you can already see a big difference the
bare soil trees are much bigger inama
genius compared to the ground cover
treatment so some results we measure the
trunk cross-sectional area for four
years and we saw already by the second
year that the ground cover treatment was
smaller than the herbicide treatment and
that trend was sustained for the next
two years so by 2011 both treatments
with groundcover had smaller trees done
the inverse or treatment which was very
similar to what we saw in the Apple
experiment if you remember those results
before in terms of yield we have only
recorded about one year yeah this is the
first important deal it was those trees
have three years and we saw that the
verso treatment had higher number of
food on more kilograms of fruit per tree
but there's no difference between the
three sides which is important is the
price of the avocado is given
not the kilograms buy more for the food
sighs so you might have less kilos but
if you have big fruit that's where you
make money so it is interesting that
even though there's difference in the
number of fruits and the kilograms
there's no difference in fruit size
under sub it's a pretty good size for
avocados in terms of soil nutrient
concentrations I know there's a lot of
data here I'll just go to the most
important part what we did we we had
here this is a repeater measurement 10
so we measured the same all of the
nutrients each year and then we analyze
them all together for the three years
and we saw we've seen some interesting
results in phosphorus calcium a Venetian
you see that this column represents the
ground cover this is the vegetative
street and this is the very soil so we
saw that actually the ground cover had
higher phosphorus and potassium than the
vegetative stream on in potassium of
both herbicide treatments and we saw
some difference significant difference
in the pH the pH in the ground cover 10
to build with higher
they are the two treatments and a very
significant difference between the three
treatments in terms of organic matter
higher in the ground cover followed by
the vegetative strip and then at the
lowest organic matter percentage in the
bursa and then in terms of total carbon
nitrogen and carbon to nitrogen ratio we
also saw a very significant difference
between the three treatments on the
ground cover had higher carbon and
nitrogen content than the bare soil in
terms of soil physical conditions we
measured the bulk density and I'm going
to explain this graph because they are
all the same de three more like this so
we have here the treatments the verso
the vegetative strip and the ground
cover and the blue column is 2009 the
green the red one is 2010 and then the
green ones 2011 so overall for the three
years the bulk density on the bare soil
treatment was higher than on the ground
cover and there was no difference
between the personal and the virtual
strip and neither was between the ground
cover and the vegetarian so it was like
in between both of them and then you can
see that they saw about the city tends
to go up on the second year a little bit
remember that this is is it's not real
soil this is the soda has been put up
together in the sperm so naturally tense
to compact because they're it's very
loose and fluffy and nice during the
first year but then you have people
walking on top of these birds and you
have the rain effect so it tends to
compact a little bit in terms of soul
microporosity we saw that the ground
cover treatment over the three years
that we measured had higher macro
porosity than the vessel and the
vegetative treatment the sole aggregate
stability the same the ground cover had
also higher aggregate stability than the
other two treatments and then as I said
in 2008 we were not able to measure the
effects of the treatment because they
were not fully established before the
end of the rainy season but we had this
baseline in where we were able to gather
data from the 15 plots who pulled them
together and this is some of the numbers
so we had we were able to record three
of rainfall events and the run of some
of the numbers are pretty high we have
over 30,000 liters of water per hectare
with a 70 millimeter rain which is very
high big number and in terms of soil
loss almost two tons per hectare and we
expected to see more rough erosion
during the first rainfall events because
of the soil was all Louis as i said but
us
the rain started compacting the soul we
see this little crust that forms on top
in the surface of the soil and you see
more runoff than erosion so the water
flows for 2009 we had five rainfall
events unfortunately I don't know well I
don't know if you're familiar with a
nino on the mini a year so then in your
year it's usually for 25 years in which
they're heavy rains and then it falls by
an Indian guides dry years so we
definitely decided to step during a
menial year because we didn't have a lot
of rainfall events but even though we
didn't have a lot of rain this numbers
are pretty impressive and only imagine
if you would have any new year where
there will be torrential rainfall if
this would be maybe 10 times more so in
2009 that it's the graph on your left
and 2010 is the rough on your right we
saw that the bare soil treatment had
higher runoff I was significantly higher
than the other two treatments and in
2009 by the third and by the fourth and
fifth event we didn't have any runoff
anymore on the ground cover treatment so
we only had run off on their bare soil
on the vegetative strip and therefore
2010 we only saw run off on their bare
so treatments both groundcover
treatments do you have any water there
was no run of all
in terms of soil us also again this is
2099 and this is 2010 2009 we saw that
the verso was significantly higher than
the other two treatments word which were
not significantly different and you see
here that this fax it is broken because
we really had very very high sediments
and soil losses in the first the first
event on the same us it happened with a
runoff of course that was not run any
one of the last two events of 2009 in
the ralphs over Christmas or we didn't
have any wrath
in terms of nutrient loss the graph here
this shows the amount of inorganic
nitrogen losses the amount of
phosphorous losses through the run of
water here we have the total nitrogen
and sulfur organic carbon this line here
separates 2009 from 2010 as I said 2010
we only had water samples from the very
soil so in 2009 we had higher losses in
the verso that on the other treatment
basically in the inorganic nitrogen and
the the four of them the phosphorus the
total legend dissolved organic carbon
the amount of nutrient loss was
significantly higher in the verse on
treatment compared with other two three
in terms of herbicide residues this is
just preliminary data are still working
on this but we run some of our samples
on we definitely saw some interesting
numbers in terms of the concentration of
her besides in this runoff water here
are the different dates start from 2008
and 2010 here are the concentrations of
terbutaline that's their residual
herbicide that we apply and these are
here showed the date in which we apply
the herbicide so here it's in the end of
June sorry in the end of July then you
have here meet a June up 2009 and here
at the beginning of August up 2010 and
you can see a little bit higher
concentrations here of herbicides
residue but but as I said up we're still
analyzing this data and most of these
are the low range concentration because
we already seen some samples that go
over 400 parts per million of
terbutaline concentration which is it's
very it's pretty high and unexpected we
also saw some turbocharged icing recipes
on the ground cover even though we
didn't have any application of the
herbicide but what's interesting is in
this big or chest you see the picture of
here is a 300-acre orchard what they do
is before they plant their plight
herbicide with an helicopter so there's
definitely a lot of drift and that's why
we saw some of ours some of some
residues on the ground cover treatment
which we didn't expect it in terms of a
soul water content in the soil we saw
some significant difference between the
treatments for only for the summer
months we observe that the treatments in
the ground cover its in green and then
you read the vegetarian ending in black
the bare soil we saw that the ground
covers tended to have a higher question
a higher content of water during the
summer months
there's not a big difference between the
year cuz this is an irrigator orchard so
there's this irrigation during the
summer but our as I said we only saw
some significant difference during the
summer for the treatment and that's
probably due to temperature difference
because in the verse all the so it's
completely exposed to the Sun and not
the case of the ground covers where it's
protected and on soil temperature we
actually didn't see any difference
between the treatments they're all the
same they all had the same note we go
difference though you can see that the
bare soil tended to be a little bit
higher also on the summer months
compared with the other two treatments
and that's because as I said it's
exposed to to the soil we also did some
good observation study which I will not
be presented because I don't think we're
going to have time and ice we're still
working on on this data so with that
I'll be more than happy to answer any
questions
no but if you have an excess of soil
moisture in you can have some problems
with fight after up but it's definitely
not the case in these orchards where you
have these firms that are actually
basically they drank everything so
that's one of the reasons that they
decided to build this firm just to avoid
phytophthora which is the biggest
problem in terms of disease from occur
in Chile
yes yeah we haven't seen any any
problems with fights after the trace
look absolutely healthy
well actually they try to filter us or
to build a verse on the opposite
direction but if you have a big rainfall
event they break all the way down
because the soil is loose in there so if
you put pressure and the water plants on
one of the sides of the verb it just
breaks down so that's why they do it the
other way and what I looking for here
it's the drainage so this is the best
way to do you think is the
sustainability of our jury system in
place for some time where you can see
yes yes you can definitely I mean it's
never been measured that's why I think
this this study is important because
it's going to give the first numbers to
the environmental effect of these
orchards but you can see some of the
orchards I'm in the soil with three
years you already see that the duration
of the soil you see after a big rainfall
event that the river that runs in the
bottom of the valley is absolutely brown
so there's a big input and contamination
of water there and that's the water that
feeds a big series there around and you
see that some of the trees tend to look
tired and they look sick and they're
what they do for that is they just keep
putting more nitrogen
oh but I went down there and I asked the
owner of the orchard which I'm very
thankful to him for letting us do this
research there I told you what we wanted
to do he's like no I mean you're
basically come to my orchard to say that
my face that I'm contaminated that I'm
doing all these horrible things I don't
want I want you to do anything here so
Michael out after talking with my
collaborators they were very helpful
with this we talked with it for and only
you know what's going to happen
eventually you're exporting all your
fruit somebody's going to tell you we
don't want your food anymore because
look what you're doing to the
environment this is not sustainable
we're not going to buy it for any more
so I told me if we don't find a way to
mitigate this corrosion and
contamination of the word that is being
produced with these orchards no nobody's
going to want to buy you food so let me
try to do these and show you what is the
faith and if we can find a way that you
can show people that at least you care
about what you're doing but your first
results indicate that ground cover
harbors condo in the ground cover feels
is not very good well but that is
because we didn't know that but
afterwards we discover that what we have
we had to do and they knew that as well
it's just to protect the first 50
centimetres of the trees just put a
protection as later here as well for the
urine I mean it's not something
outrageous and they unless something
horrible possible and feasible to do is
not
that it means much much more extra work
so even though the some of the data show
that there's less fruit and that we're
producing less well that was the same
results that we saw on the Apple
experiment the first year yeah we see
that their personal treatments the trees
on the verso applause do much better but
that is not something that it's going to
be sustained every time and then
probably we're going to see because the
erosion and the effect of the run-up
it's going to be much more negative than
in the case of the study that will be
here when we didn't have that slope
we're going to see that the trees on the
birth of treatment are going to decline
and the trace on the ground cover
treatments I'm going to stabilize and
they're going to be able to compensate
for that competition because we have a
rotational because we fertilize them the
experiment going
yes the poor my clever is down until are
very very very interested in this
experiment and they are replicated on
other rituals
yes but in that case if you don't it
would be better for the trees but known
for the soil under motion because the
first year is when you get the highest
volume of study man's loss so I think
that what it would be the best thing to
do is that when they prepare the soil to
sit the ground cover right away even
before they put the trees because that
way they are already protected that's
were necessary near there actually
that's what that's what we're looking at
into our word data so that's one of the
questions we want to answer to see how
did those words go and if they actually
cover what safety is the entire firm and
they go all the way one meter because if
that's not the case well the smaller the
burn it would mean less erosion as well
Oh
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu